Speaker 1: . So against my better judgment,
I decided over this past weekend to do live
coverage of the Mike Lyndell, my pillow frank
speech rally in Wisconsin, and I always love
being with you guys, love sharing events with
the live audience.
But this one was really, really tough to watch.
It was truly an historic event organized by
Mike Lyndell, a big Trump supporter, founder
and CEO of the My Pillow Brand.
It was a four hour event.
I was only able to get through about two and
a half hours before I just had to bail.
The line up at this event included Mike Lyndell
himself, Diamond and Silk, Charlie Kirk, Branon
Howse, Chris Cox, Dinesh D'Souza, Danielle
de Souza, Sheriff Clarke, and, of course,
Donald Trump himself joining the event via
video conference.
Now, 99 percent of what happened at this event
was merely the disgusting nonsense you would
expect.
The event had a scheduled flyover.
It failed.
I guess the planes, like, didn't show up.
It was really weird, but it was really capped
off by Donald Trump delivering a deranged
and bizarre speech during which his eyes appeared
almost completely swollen shut.
We've seen this with Trump a couple of times
before.
He was also slurring and seemed to be engaged
in a real battle against his own tongue, which
was determined apparently to prevent him from
being able to enunciate anything clearly.
And this rally, while disgusting and depraved,
it really confirmed our suspicions.
They seem fully intent on riding this horse
into the twenty, twenty two election.
That's the Trump horse.
And they will see how far it gets them.
Trump launching right into his entire I actually
won the election thing.
The talking points have been the same for
six months and Trump just labored, struggling
to speak.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: We went from sixty three million
votes and we won to seventy five million people.
And they say we lost, but we didn't lose.
Seventy five million votes.
They say that we lost.
Now I was told by John McLaughlin, who's considered
just about the best pollster, I would say
the best pollster.
There's a few of them out there towering.
There are a few of them out there that are
great.
Sir, you got 63 million.
If you can go up to sixty five, you can't
lose the election.
Well, you know what happened?
We went up to seventy five and they say we
lost the election.
If you win Miami, if you win Florida, if you
take out and win and we won by a lot Florida
and Ohio and then you add Iowa.
Nobody's ever won those states and lost.
But we won those states in virtual landslides
and they have us losing and there are so many.
We held every state house.
We held Congress.
You know, it's
Speaker 1: all so labored.
And of course, it's the same lies week after
week.
As you can hear, the crowd is not exactly
riveted by what Donald Trump is saying here.
Is Donald Trump delivering a defense of, I
guess, Rudy Giuliani.
But it's hard to tell if he really means it,
but just not looking good, not sounding good.
I want to
Speaker 2: thank people like Rudy Giuliani,
who is out there fighting and they're after
him.
And they want to take him down.
They want to take us all down.
There's never been a time like this.
There's never been it's weaponized.
It's weaponized.
And the Republicans were very nice.
Our people were very, very nice and very,
very respectful.
And I said this would happen.
But Rudy is a great patriot.
He was the greatest mayor in the history of
New York and a great, great patriot.
And what he's done and what Mike has done
and what so many other people have done.
These are incredible heroes and they're going
to go down as heroes someday and I think is
someday in the not too distant future.
So I look forward to being with you.
Speaker 1: Hopefully they go down, but not
as heroes.
Hopefully they just go down for their crimes
and misdeeds.
Then here is Trump really just fighting that
tongue to enunciate coherently, saying China
should pay the world for the virus.
But kind of weird.
Yeah, take a look.
Speaker 2: And the China virus, they have
to pay reparations.
We've been hurt so badly in terms of deaths,
human life and in terms of monetarily to a
level that they have to pay us.
And frankly, if they paid us 10 trillion dollars,
that wouldn't cover it.
But they really have to pay the world because
this has started in the world.
The entire world has been not only disrupted
Speaker 1: and just the slurring the the eyes
almost completely shut during this next segment.
And then the video froze, which in a sense
was like the best moment of the rant when
the video froze,
Speaker 2: having a hard time with the contractors.
You know contractors better than anyone.
They're very brilliant.
They may not read or write in some cases,
but you know what?
They're smarter than the rest.
Smarter.
So I just want to thank everybody.
Speaker 1: The video freezing seem to get
the crowd more interested than anything Trump
had said up until that point.
At another moment, Donald Trump falsely claimed
to have stopped the Russian oil pipeline like
it just didn't happen.
It just factually untrue.
Speaker 2: I stopped the Russian pipeline,
probably the biggest pipeline in the world,
going into Germany and other countries in
Europe.
It was stopped.
Speaker 1: Never happened.
Just it didn't happen.
It's not true.
A few other really strange moments here.
Diamond and Silk apparently explaining something
about the so-called audit in Arizona of the
absentee ballots.
See if you can understand this
Speaker 3: question for me.
OK, I notice how the Democrats is trying to
interfere and it's codification of the audit.
Oh, by the way, I remember them saying that
the insurrection when you tried to block the
certification.
So my question is, if they're trying to interfere
and the honest in Arizona, for example, that
that make them an insurrection because they're
trying to stop the verification of the stratification
of Jimtown Joe.
Good way of looking at
Speaker 1: that, I don't know, guys, that's
pretty strong, I'm pretty convinced I don't
know of what, but I'm pretty convinced by
that.
Another favorite moment was when Mike Lyndell
claimed that I guess a friend of his had he
was banned from Google Maps.
Speaker 2: Really weird to a friend of mine.
About a month ago, I was on his radio show
and they put up he sent it out the podcast
to all this.
He emailed it out 30000 emails.
Google took away his Gmail and his Google
Maps.
I want you to think about that.
They took away his Google Maps.
Speaker 1: I feel like I need an interpreter
to even understand what it is they are claiming.
Like I'm having trouble even adjudicating
the claims that are being made by these people
because I don't even know what the claims
are.
And then lastly, maybe the funniest moment.
This is a crowd heading for the exits while
Mike Lyndell is speaking.
Apparently, the crowd had had enough
Speaker 2: and the greatest revival for Jesus
in the history of the world and.
But I want to tell you, I'm going to tell
you what I want to do is I want to bring it
back because how did I end up here?
How did we end up here today, especially when
I, you know, here's an extract out from Minnesota.
So I'm going to tell you a little, oh, bring
you back in time, you know?
Speaker 1: So if you're listening today and
not watching, the crowd was just heading out
while Mike Lendell was speaking.
This is one of my favorite segments from the
Trump era is a segment where Trump went to
India and this big stadium full of people
started heading towards the exits as Donald
Trump was speaking and mispronouncing all
sorts of Indian names.
This was the equivalent.
This was the equivalent during the Mike Lendell
rally.
So another completely humiliating event, but
signaling a few things to us.
Number one, the Trump crowd doesn't seem to
be that worried about sunburn.
And the reason I say that is this was a four
hour event which opened two hours early and
people just sitting in the blazing hot sun
the entire time.
I hope they brought sunscreen, but they don't
seem super concerned about sun exposure.
That's one thing we learned.
And number two, they really seem to be on
this.
They're not changing horses midstream, I think
would be the metaphor that we would apply
to this.
They seem committed to at least seeing what
Trump ism is going to bring them through 2022.
If it fails, then maybe they'll go a different
direction.
But yet another complete and total embarrassment,
not to be outdone by Marjorie Taylor Green,
although she's trying.
Let's talk about
that next.